Heavenly Father this morning I want to
thank you for a new day of life father I
want to thank you for the beautiful
sunshine
father help us to remember that this day
is a gift from you and in it you have a
purpose for us father help us to fulfill
that purpose today
the things that you have for us to learn
today father I pray that you will
illuminate our minds that we can learn
that we can grasp hold of those things
that you want to reveal to us
father I pray that you would be with me
as as I speak words to these students
may they not be my own father but I just
pray for the inspiration of your Holy
Spirit this morning
and father I just pray that we would all
gain a clearer understanding of the
subject we're studying that of the
spirit of Prophecy and we ask and pray
these things in Jesus name amen
all right we are going to pick up where
we left off last time does anybody
remember where we left off
huh
okay heart is deceitful what section do
you know we where we were of course in
what section I gave you hand out
afterwards
we were talking about
ah the role of the prophets we talked
about the spiritual gifts we talked
about the types of prophets yes we we
were talking we we ended up in Ephesians
4. you remember and Paul's list of in
Ephesians 4 Paul's list of the purpose
that God gave spiritual gifts
okay
um now before I jump right into that
just a little bit of review a prophet
Bible definition a prophet is what
okay man when do you guys wake up 10 30
11 two hours he says up here
a spokesperson for God okay
um
who is it that we the scripture told us
especially speaks through the voice of
the prophet
the spirit of Prophecy is the testimony
of Jesus Christ
so it's Jesus who speaks through the
Prophet The Prophet is especially the
spokesperson of Jesus Christ
and what are some of the reasons that we
looked at last time for the gift of
Prophecy in God's Church oh let me back
up
what did God use the prophets to do
something that that some some he's what
is an essential task God gave the
prophets that with without which you and
I would not be here likely
what did it what task did God give the
prophets
I don't want to word that
he gave them instruction but what did
they do that brought you and I here
what's that
guide and protect and
they wrote the Bible
they wrote the Bible the Bible is the
revelation of God to you and I right
this is God's divine revelation to us
and it came to us through the voices of
prophets through the hands of prophets
as they wrote out the things that they
were shown
what
are some of the purposes that we looked
at last time for the gift of Prophecy
in the church
okay doctrinal they bring us to
doctrinal Unity that's an important one
we talk quite a bit about that
equipping the Saints for
for Ministry
there's no such thing
hold on just a minute with that thought
there's no such thing as a
non-ministering saint amen you know that
if you gotta if you got a religion that
says well that's just not my bag
something's wrong with your religion
the purpose of Christianity is to make
us ministers for Jesus Christ
though you never get behind a Pulpit or
whatever the casement you yet you're
always a minister did you know we're
always Witnesses always
that's right you may be a good one and
you may be a bad one
isn't that right people watch you you
take the name of Jesus Christ and you
say I'm a Christian people are watching
to see whether you really are a
Christian you're always a witness
either good witness or a bad witness and
we're all to be ministers the Holy
Spirit was given is given to all who
accept Jesus Christ and are baptized we
have to be baptized both by water and
the spirit when you're baptized by the
spirit you receive a gift
and the purpose for the gift is Ministry
he equips us for Ministry and so don't
tell me you're not equipped amen amen
if you're telling me you're not equipped
for Ministry what are you telling me
you haven't been baptized in the spirit
and you're not a Christian
you follow that
you agree with me
all right
that's what the Bible says
okay so to equip the Saints for Ministry
Mark you said something else there
okay to bring us to character maturity
in Christ
how long does that take
you're asking the same question aren't
you
it's the work of a lifetime the work of
sanctification
and and the the how how do you and I
grow up into Christ
tell me how we grow up into Christ
glory to glory give me some prayer
what's that
diet yourself what how what what what
what what is it that that helps that to
happen
beholding him where do we Behold Him
Behold Him in the word
the word is essential the gift that
here's you know the spiritual gifts and
it's not just the gift of Prophecy as we
said in in Ephesians 4 he's talking
about all the gifts the purpose is to
bring us to character maturity
and character maturity
comes in a large part by learning the
will of God
and by the grace of God putting it into
practice in our lives right
Christianity is a living
religion
right it's not a one day a week religion
so let's pick up
those are some of the some did somebody
have something else they want to bring
up as to the work some of the
now the first one we looked at was in
Ephesians 2 20 does that ring about
anybody
the foundation
the prophets and the apostles laid the
foundation
it was through their witness that we
understand what the foundation of the
faith is
and we talked a little bit about that
into the the writing of the scriptures
let's look at some other things let's go
and if you have the handout from last
time you can kind of follow along it's
on number three under section c
um
David I'd give you one of these if I I
don't know if I have one up here or not
foreign
does anybody have an extra one around
all right
Acts chapter 13 verses 1 and 2. this is
another reason
that the gift of Prophecy was given to
the church to initiate
and coordinate the missionary work of
the church now what we're doing
is we're trying to understand what the
Bible role of a prophet is
so then when we come to Ellen White and
we see her in certain offices we can say
hey guess what this is exactly what the
Bible says a prophet should do
Acts chapter 13
verses one and two does anybody want to
read that for me acts 13 1 and 2.
okay go ahead now when the church there
was that Antioch there were certain
prophets and teachers Barnabas Simeon
who's called Niger Lucius of Cyrene
manian who had been brought up with
Herod the toucharch and Saul as they
ministered to the Lord and fasted the
holy spirit said now separate to me
Barnabas and Saul for the work to which
I have called them
okay
now What's Happening Here
there are several prophets and teachers
in the early church and God comes to
these prophets and he tells them to do
what
separate unto me Barnabas and Saul I
want you to pull these guys aside and
give them a direction send them get them
out and coordinate as you have there to
initiate and coordinate the missionary
work of the church is that what they're
doing
they're setting in the side for what
what are they setting aside Barnabas and
Saul for
for the work it says in verse 3 then
having fasted and prayed they laid hands
on them and sent them away what'd they
do send them home
they sent him to do ministry right okay
they send them out on their mission
let's look at acts 16 and verse 6.
reading here verses 6 through 10.
who would like to read this for me yes
ma'am could you please tell me here's
I'm going to do this okay today I'm
going to try to get your names down and
I've seen and your names I've talked to
some of you but it's just I'm not just
I'm not really good with names how many
of you are not good with names you talk
to somebody say brother what's your name
Ron how you doing Ron it's nice to meet
you you know I'll go over here and I'll
talk to you and then I'll see Ron two
minutes later and say
what's your name and that's that's how I
do I'm terrible with that so if I ask
you several times don't be offended
please but I want to try to get your
name so what I'm going to ask you I'm
going to ask if you tell me your name
too before you read
Chandra okay Ron
Jack Jack okay Chandra could you read 16
acts 16 verses 6 through 10.
yeah don't you love to get all those you
know
but the spirit suffered them not
you're doing very well by the way
and prayed and prayed him saying come
over into Macedonia and help us and
after he had seen the vision immediately
we endeavored to go into Macedonia
assuredly Gathering that the Lord had
Gathering that the Lord had called us
for to preach the gospel unto them okay
now what happened here tell me somebody
break it down for me what's just
happened what did we read about
let me let me put this up here okay you
didn't know this
but when I teach
not only is it
on the spirit of Prophecy but it's also
reading
comprehension
101 okay
because when we go through a text I
can't tell you how many times I'll read
through a text and we go through this
one and we go through this one and we go
through this one and I ask people and
they go
with you what does that mean
now if you and I know all the Bible and
we read through all the texts but we
can't say what it's saying if we can't
communicate that then what good has it
done us
and we're going to get into this in this
class something you need to understand
there is something different about the
Bible
and about any inspired writings like the
writings of Ellen White they do not read
like storybooks
there are books and I know that you know
this that you can pick up and read
through in an afternoon man I couldn't
put it down
the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy
aren't quite the same way
they're deep
even when they're not deep they're deep
there's something in there it it it's
not something you skim over they're not
the funny papers right
seriously now listen you know one of the
things Helen White gave Counsel on in
her day was that we steer away from the
reading of novels
now do you know why she said that
she's break down the line
she says actually it would destroy the
relish for reading spiritual things see
what happens is you train your mind to
for for pablum
you trained your mind for this simple
comic book stuff and you get to the
Bible and you just don't want to yeah
you can skim over it but the Bible you
get the most out of it when you meditate
upon it
and so you know when you go through a
passage sometimes it's like what's that
say well it doesn't just jump off the
page like uh Calvin and Hobbes but
anybody even know who Calvin and Hobbes
are all right
anyway
that's not Essential Knowledge but the
idea is either the Bible takes thinking
through
and so I'm going to ask you when you
read something you know and it doesn't
have to be the person who read it what
is the text saying what basically
happened I don't want you to give me
some you have to give me some deep
theological thing it's just here we read
an experience in Acts chapter 16 what
just happened
break it down for me
okay say that again I had I suggested
traveling in the hill
in the Holy okay how'd the Holy Spirit
lead them foreign
okay who'd he tell
Paul you knew Paul was a prophet right
Paul had the gift of Prophecy God came
to the prophet and what did he tell the
prophet
go preach where
Macedonia okay so one of the roles of
the province so Paul says to is the
guy's with him he says to Luke he says
to Barnabas he says hey let's go they
need us over in Macedonia Donia how did
he know that
the Lord revealed it to him and the Holy
Spirit through the gift of Prophecy
directed the missionary efforts of the
church
you see that
see that's important because when you
and I come into Ellen White's writings
and you've already seen this I'm sure
Ellen White directed listen we wouldn't
have the educational institutions we
wouldn't have the hospital work we
wouldn't have the mission work we would
not be
you know there are a lot of people that
talk about church girls today right you
go to Willow Creek we're going to teach
you guys how to grow churches you've got
these guys oh wow they've got 30 000.
they've got 30 000 people coming to this
church they're going to teach us Church
growth
are they worldwide churches
who ought to be teaching who
we are a worldwide church we are in more
parts of the world than any church with
the exception of the Roman Catholic
Church isn't that interesting
okay two worldwide players
why because God guided this church
through the gift of Prophecy
the apostles
in the in the early the early church
inside the first century had spread the
gospel to the then known world
and The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
within 60 years of its Inception from a
small group of people in New England
became a worldwide movement
I mean that's awesome and that wouldn't
have happened
without the guidance of the gift of
Prophecy I can tell you that with a
certainty but this is what we see in the
scripture this is how we see the early
church guided so to initiate and
coordinate the missionary work of the
church
that's one of the reasons for the gift
of Prophecy
I want you to look at another section
now here with me that next number four
on that handout I gave you the other day
to Enlighten and give spiritual
discernment now I think this is
fascinating this little
these texts we're going to look at the
first one I want you to go to with me
is first Samuel 9 and verse 9.
first Samuel 9 and verse 9.
now here I'm going to tell you something
else I'm going to do too
I gave you the handouts on Friday and I
gave you the handouts last and I told
you I did that because I wanted you to
do what write notes but I'm taking that
back
I'm not a prophet nor am I the son of a
prophet I have aired and I will confess
that because I would rather I'm going to
hand out the handout to you next time be
first because I would rather have you
paying attention
I know a lot of times what happens is
I've talked to people that I was so busy
taking notes I couldn't get everything
here's the notes now listen
okay
and I'm not going to tell you you can't
take notes I mean you do what you need
to do but uh I'm just saying
these things are really important for us
first Samuel 9 9 who wants to read first
Samuel 9 9 for me
and Stephen
all right
God he used to say come and let us go to
the Seer where he who is called the
prophet now was formerly called a Seer
okay
a prophet used to be called a Seer the
Bible says now I'm not going to look at
all the texts I'm going to reference you
have them right there first Corinthians
12 12 to 27 in First Corinthians 12 Paul
speaks of God's church as a what
does anybody know First Corinthians 12.
as a body a body made up of
are all eyes
are all ears are all big toes no a body
made up of
different parts okay
that's an awesome chapter by the way
what does that tell us
the bodies made up of all these
different parts and Paul says we each
have a part you can there's nobody who
can say well I'm just so insignificant I
can't I'll have as good memory as this
guy and I Don't Preach like this one and
I don't
doesn't matter
everybody has a part in God's Church
God's Church operates best when the
whole body is functioning
look my head's fine it was my stomach
this morning that bothered me
you ever have that happen to you
it'll ruin your whole day just that one
little part
and so the whole body works together now
if the body follow me here if the body
if the church is a body made up of many
parts what part of the body would the
prophet be
if you were to put the profit in a part
a profit used to be called
a seer
okay what part would the prophet be
eyes do you follow that
okay go with me to revelation 3.
yes ma'am
I don't know I wasn't paying attention
to that thank you for see that
she's sharp I don't know though why it
I'm guessing first of all you know
parenthetical Expressions were not uh
inserted by the original text
I'm just guessing that the interpreters
saw that as being a parenthetical type
phrase
it yeah formerly in Israel it just seems
to be apparent they they saw that as not
having a direct fitting directly in the
context it was more parenthetical
so that would be my
what did what did I say we're going to
Revelation 3 Revelation chapter three
you guys know where I'm going I think
Revelation chapter 3 and if we pick up
in Revelation 3 verse 14
the Bible says
and to the angel of the Church of the
who of the laodiceans right these things
says the amen the faithful and true
witness the beginning of the creation of
God
I know your works that you are neither
hot cold nor hot now one thing also
that's interesting this is kind of a
side note but
what's the first thing that Jesus says
to every Church in Revelation
what's the very first thing he says you
know this is these are Jesus is the one
coming he's the faithful and true
witness he's coming to each church he he
sends the message by the angel
but basically somebody wrote a book
Taylor bunch one of our Pioneers wrote a
book that called the they called the
Epistles of Jesus you know you get the
Epistle of Paul to the Romans you've got
the epistle Paul to the Philippians the
first Epistle of Peter these are letters
that Jesus sent to the churches you can
call them the Epistles of Jesus
at any rate
what's the first thing he says to each
one of the seven churches
I know that works
so everybody making a big deal but ah
all that matters is just that you
believe
well like Ellen White said that's true
in the fullest sense but most people
don't take it in the full sense Jesus
doesn't come and say I know your faith
the first thing he says to every church
is I Know Thy works why
because your Works tell what kind of
Faith you have
Ellen White says a man will work out all
the faith that he has
is that true
if you believe in something you'll do
something about it won't you
what if I was sitting in an easy chair
and I said boy I think this house is on
fire
I really think it's a big blaze in fact
I think it's so bad I don't think I
don't I think it's getting to the point
that if I don't hurry I'm going to get
burned up in this place
and I'm still sitting there are you
gonna believe me I'm probably not going
to be very convincing is it
if you believe something you'd act on it
aren't you
well anyway
Revelation 3 he says to this laodicean
church I know your works
your neither neither hot cold nor hot I
wish you were cold or hot verse 16 so
then because you are lukewarm
and neither cold nor Han I will vomit
you out of my mouth because you say I'm
rich have become wealthy and have need
of nothing and do not know that you are
wretched miserable poor blind and naked
I counsel you to buy from me gold tried
in the fire that you may be rich and
white garments that you may be clothed
that the shame of your nakedness may not
appear and anoint your eyes with isab
that you may see
as many as I love I rebuke and Chase and
therefore be zealous and
repent behold I stand at the door and
knock he says we love that text behold I
stand at the door and knock Jesus is
knocking at the door
but I like what Ellen White says in
commenting on this she says Jesus is
going around door to door as the
heavenly merchantment
I've got something to sell today
how much does it cost it doesn't cost
anything I've got gold
I've got white Raymond and I've got isaf
no thanks don't need any gold I'm rich
got all I need in here
well how about some uh White Raymond do
you need no no got all the my clothes
are just fine
would you like some some ice have
no this is what's happening
and until you have a sense that you need
what he's selling so to speak you're not
gonna what
open the door
and the key to opening the door is where
he says if anyone hears my voice
and opens the door right before that it
says as many as I love I rebuke and
Chase and therefore be zealous and what
repent repent to me repent basically
means in this context to admit that you
need the gold tried and the fire the
faith purified
by love
you've got need of white raiment the
righteousness of Christ
and you've got need of ice have that is
spiritual discernment now what I find
interesting is you and I know this
laodicean church this is the last day of
church
this is the condition of the Sleepy last
day Church
Jesus does not rebuke this church for
their doctrines it's not doctrinal
errors that have
brought this church down but it's a
spirit it's a spirit of complacency oh
we got everything we need we're good
Christians we go to church on the right
day
we pay tithe
we got the spirit of Prophecy this is
fine do you listen to it do you pay
attention to it is your heart in it
a condition of the last day church is
that it is a blind Church
and I believe
that the isaf that Jesus Christ has
offered to the last day church is the
gift of Prophecy
I save
because they're blind it's not they're
not physically blind that's not the
issue here these are spiritual
conditions they're spiritually blind
they lack spiritual discernment
they say
well I don't know what's the difference
between the Baptist Church and us other
than the day
they lack spiritual discernment
well this person says he's a Christian
and that person says they're a Christian
we all love Jesus
that they lack spiritual discernment I'm
going to tell you there are big issues
in the last days
but those who see things on the surface
are not seeing things as they really are
and of course they lack the spiritual
discernment to see their own true
condition
so I believe that one of the roles of
the gift of Prophecy is outlined in the
scripture clearly they have that
role of giving Vision to the Church of
giving sight to the church they're seers
and I believe that Revelation 3 points
us to the fact that the last day church
is going to have the gift of Prophecy
just like some other texts we're going
to look at do you follow me
does that make sense
let's look at another one there right
along the same line Second Peter chapter
one
second Peter chapter one
and verse 16.
second Peter 1 verse 16 to 21. boy I
love this passage
this is awesome who wants to read this
for me all right your name
Kevin
all right Kevin uh verse second Peter
chapter 1 verses 16 to 21.
for we did not follow cleverly and
coming of our Lord Jesus Christ instead
we were eyewitnesses of his majesty for
when he received honor and Glory from
God the Father a voice came to him from
The Majestic Glory this is my beloved
Son I take Delight in here
and we heard this voice when it came
from Heaven while we were with him on
the Holy Mountain
so we have the prophetic word strongly
confirmed you will do well to pay
attention to it as to the lamp shining
in a dismal place until the day Dawns
and The Morning Star arises in your
hearts
first of all you should know this no
prophecy of scripture comes from one's
own interpretation because no prophecy
ever came by the will of man instead
moved by the Holy Spirit men spoke from
God
okay now we're we're going to get in a
little bit more into the whole private
interpretation idea further on
here's what I want you to get first of
all he says he starts out saying we
didn't follow any cleverly devised
cunningly devised fables it says in the
new King James but we were what
we're what
eyewitnesses we didn't follow any
cunningly devious fables we didn't make
this stuff up we're not following
somebody's cleverly contrived fairy tale
we're eyewitnesses to what we're telling
you about that's how he starts out
he says for he receives speaking of
Jesus eyewitnesses of the Lord Jesus
Christ verse 17 for he received from God
the Father honor and Glory when a voice
Came From Heaven saying this is my
beloved Son in whom I'm well pleased and
we heard this voice which came from
heaven when we were with him where
what's he talking about
everybody get that the Mount of
transfiguration some of you may not have
heard that before I don't know you can
see it in Matthew 17 verse 1. we're not
going there right now Matthew 17 verse 1
and following you find Jesus up and this
isn't his baptism you say maybe
initially oh we heard the voice when
this is my beloved Son or whom I want
please so that's the baptism no because
it says well it's when we were with him
in the Holy Mountain and you go back and
you see that this is the experience
where Jesus Took up Peter James and John
this is Peter writing
and he took them up into the mountain
and he was glorified there and Moses and
Elijah appeared and Peter thought he'd
come to set up his kingdom and he says
this is great let's set up a tent for
Moses Elijah we're going to conquer Rome
you know and then he got the wrong idea
like he often did like they often did
and yet Jesus was glorified there and
they saw him glorified
and so Peter is now witnessing here and
he's saying hey we were eyewitnesses of
His Majesty of his glory
now here's the powerful part
how many of you wish you could have been
there and seen Jesus glorified amen
how many of you
well let's let's let's go on here so he
says in verse 19 after he has kind of
laid this out I I really like how the
King James reads here the new King James
says we have the prophetic word
confirmed similar to what you read what
were you reading from Kevin
okay
is that that new translation somebody
was telling me there was a fairly yeah
yeah I had a church member who got one
of those
you like it I do all right it's very
similar to this one now the King James
version says what though
we have the
more sure word of Prophecy now here's
what I like about this see I think it
gets the sense across what Peter's
saying
Peter's saying I saw it I was an
eyewitness to it but he says we have
more sure word of Prophecy more sure
than what
more sure than I Witness
so you know I said man I wish I could
have been there but I want to tell you
what you and I have more here than Peter
had there
he says we have that why why would why
would I say that why would anybody say
that we have the Bible's more sure than
what I see
why would I say that the Bible is more
sure than what I see
your senses can deceive you are we going
to see things brothers and sisters in
the coming days are we going to see
things even today
that may not be in accordance with the
Bible
Supernatural things
yeah that's that's Peter's Point here is
Peter says we have the more sure word of
Prophecy
which you do well to heed as a what
as a light in a dark place remember
we're talking about the prophet's role
to Enlighten and give spiritual
discernment just like when you want
anybody walk into a dark room that you
are unfamiliar with
what happened
right
you walk into stuff
nah Peter says it's the same way
when you and I do not have the light of
the word
you follow that
we have the more sure word of Prophecy
that shines as a light in a dark place
there's nothing like finding a light
when you're in that place and you're
walking around and you're ah the light
switch and you know where you are
that's how he's equating this gift
of Prophecy the prophetic word here
speaking especially in regard to the
scriptures
you do well to heed it as a light that
shines in a dark place what's the
implication
what's it mean you do well to heed it
to pay attention what's the implication
here
if you don't heat it
you're going to stumble just like you
would if the lights were off in a dark
room that you were unfamiliar with okay
is it important to heed
the prophetic word
it's a light that shines in a dark place
the role of the gift of Prophecy one of
the roles here to Enlighten and give
spiritual discernment I'm taking more
time on this one than I will on some of
these others but this one I think is
especially important one more I want you
to look at with me there is in First
Corinthians chapter one it says verse
six but we're going to look at a few
more verses than that
verse 6 is where we're targeting but I I
want you to get the context of this I
think this is powerful in First
Corinthians chapter one
I want you to start who wants to read
for me by the way
okay
I want you to read the whole chapter no
I'm
verses four through who did it let me
see those hands again dude I didn't pick
anybody I saw some hands and then I
didn't pick anybody okay why don't we
start back with Vesna and then we'll
come and you guys
Ben you're gonna be last the first shall
be last you know rather you're up front
so
um
Verses 4 through let's go through 10.
Verses 4 through 10 of First Corinthians
chapter 1.
so that you are not lacking in any
spiritual gift as you wait for the
revealing of our Lord Jesus Christ who
will sustain you to the end Guiltless in
the day of our Lord Jesus Christ God is
faithful by whom you are called into the
fellowship of his son Jesus Christ Our
Lord I appeal to you Brothers by the
name of our Lord Jesus Christ let all of
you agree and that there be no divisions
among you but you be United in the same
mind and the same judgment oh that's
powerful
isn't that awesome
like what are you talking about Pastor
let's look at this for a minute let's
look at verse four now look at the
church I want you to get this Paul's
speaking to this church look at some of
the characteristics of this church okay
and see if you can relate
verse 4 he says I thank God for my God
always concerning you verse 5 that you
were enriched in everything by Him in
all what okay speech or utterance what
does that mean they're enriched in
speech or utterance tell me something
about this church
what does it mean to be enriched in
speech and utterance
when you're preaching okay their
preaching has power
their speech has power and they're
enriched it's not talking about human
powers talking about divine power God
has given this church a special blessing
in their preaching
you follow that in all utterance and in
all what
knowledge in all utterance
and in all knowledge I'm not going to
put utterance up there I'm going to put
speech up there I'm going to put
preaching up there okay
knowledge tell me that to explain that a
little bit
what does it mean
what does it mean they're enriched in
all knowledge
understanding okay we could call this
spiritual discernment couldn't we
now I like the next part but best and I
didn't like your Bible there on that one
but we count we pointed that out the
other day it said the testimony in her
Bible what did it say even as the
testimony what
about Jesus Christ
it says here and you'll see that you'll
you'll catch this as we look at it
you are enriched by everything in Him in
all utterance and in all knowledge even
as the testimony of what
Christ was confirmed in you and how do
we know that has to do how do you know
Pastor you're saying the testimony of
Christ you're saying this is the
testimony of Jesus the gift of Prophecy
but but that how do you know it's not
the testimony about Christ look at the
next verse so that you come short in
what
no
gift
The Testament of Christ was confirmed in
you the spirit of Prophecy was given to
you so that you come short in no gift
you follow that
but here's the here's the point that I
want you to look at he says
even
this is New King James as
you've been enriched by him
he says you he's enriched uh you were
enriched in everything by him Jesus
Christ in all utterance and in all
knowledge and all preaching and all
understanding even as
the testimony of Christ was confirmed in
you what does that mean even as
okay a while
even as
you were enriched in this even as this
was given to you
I'm going to put this okay
two
the
same
degree
do you follow that
you were in it God has enriched you
Corinthian Church in your preaching and
in your understanding of Truth to the
same degree that you accept the gift of
Prophecy that's been given to your
church
you follow that
let me ask you a question have we a
Seventh-Day Adventist been enlightened
have has have we been given powerful
preaching based on the light that's come
through the spirit of Prophecy
I want to tell you brothers and sisters
I've been to different churches
and we do have dead Seventh-day
Adventist churches
but when there are Seventh-day
Adventists that believe in our message
there's no you can't that preaching you
can't beat it anywhere
you just don't have power in the
preaching I mean I've heard some
powerful sermons
by non-seventh Day Adventist but the
fact of the matter is that God has
enlightened our Us in preaching and I'll
tell you those dead
sermons that you hear
I'd almost guarantee you there's a
problem right here
they're not being enriched but well we
don't want to take out Ellen White on
everything we're just gonna I don't I
don't put much stock in her anymore
your preaching is going to go
understanding
I pre I preach I preach primarily from
the scriptures I'll bring up Spirit or
prophecy statements here and there
I do an evangelicalistic series it's all
from uh the scripture
and then I'll tell you right now and
somebody says how do you know what you
know
to the same degree brothers and sisters
as I have
meditated upon what God has given us in
the spirit of Prophecy
the spirit of Prophecy writings will
enrich you in your understanding
and too many seven how many of you in
here have grown up Seventh-day Adventist
you don't understand I would just about
guarantee
as you could understand
how much light you have and maybe you do
but we take a lot of things for granted
we take a lot of things for granted that
we know we just think everybody knows it
that's why we say well I can't I can't
witness for the Lord you'd be surprised
what people don't know
that that we know did we just take it
for granted
so
the gift of Prophecy was given to
Enlighten and give spiritual discernment
spiritual understanding to God's Church
without it you're walking in darkness
and we'll we'll flesh this out a little
bit more
as we go but keep in mind who gave the
gift of Prophecy
God did right here he says Jesus has
enriched the church in all things God
through Jesus Christ has enriched this
church notice go on there in in First
Corinthians chapter
one even as a testimony of Christ was
confirmed in you verse 7 so that you
come short in no gift eagerly waiting
for the what
revelation of Jesus Christ wow look at
this here's a church that's got powerful
preaching that has a great understanding
of what the scriptures of the message of
scripture to the same degree that
they've got the gift of Prophecy and
they're waiting for Jesus to come
that sound familiar
that kind of sounds like the Seventh
Adventist Church to me
especially when you get into Corinthians
and you see all the problems in the
Corinthian Church
but it didn't mean that they weren't
enriched in these areas did it God can
work through the problems
so he says who will confirm you to the
end that you may be blameless
in the day of our Lord Jesus Christ I'm
going to divert a little here on this
just briefly says he's going to part of
this church they're waiting for Jesus
and they believe that Jesus is going to
confirm them to the end so that they
will be blameless in the day of Christ
coming
I look this up for fun once the word
blameless in the Greek is the word
anacletos this is what it says and in
clitos
in the vines expository dictionary of
New Testament Greek words not merely an
acquittal
but the absence of even
the absence of even a charge or an
accusation
not merely an acquittal but blameless
means not even a charge
and what it made me think of is the
statement in great controversy page 620.
where Ellen White says that when Christ
comes God's people try as they may to
remember their sins will not be able to
bring their sins to remembrance because
they've gone beforehand a judgment and
been blotted out
blameless this is our message they've
been enriched by the gift of Prophecy
and they're preaching and their
understanding to the same degree that
they're following the gift of Prophecy
that's been given to them
and they're looking forward eagerly to
the coming of Jesus Christ expecting
that he by his grace not by their own
abilities is going to make them
blameless so they can stand blameless
and see the Lord coming without ever
seeing death
man
that's exciting stuff to me
I think that's awesome
anyway
God is faithful he says in verse 9 by
whom you were called into the Fellowship
of the son Jesus Christ Our Lord verse
10. now I plead with you Brethren by the
name of the Lord Jesus that you what
speak the same thing
Let There Be Noah divisions among you
but that you be perfectly joined
together in the same mind and in the
same judgment isn't this what we looked
at already with a gift of Prophecy it's
to bring us to Unity of the faith so we
get a big we kind of get a whole
overarching picture here in First
Corinthians of what I believe is just a
church that's in the same boat as
Seventh-day Adventist Church
in many ways
so the gift of Prophecy is given to
Enlighten and give spiritual discernment
to God's people
uh the next one I'm just I'm we're not
even I'm not even going to look at this
uh as far as the texts go number five
because we've looked at a lot of them to
preserve Unity of belief and to prevent
doctrinal confusion especially in times
of controversy we've already seen that
the one mind and the one judgment here
the the degree that they have received
the spirit of Prophecy increases their
power and preaching and their
understanding in Ephesians chapter four
it said that they would not be tossed to
and fro with every wind of Doctrine okay
the gift of Prophecy one of the reasons
it was given to was to preserve that
Unity of belief especially in times of
doctrinal confusion confusion the acts
15 text there if you've gone through the
whole chapter of Acts 15 there was a
dispute
there was a dispute among
the church over the issue of
circumcision
anybody read this before in Acts 15.
there's a dispute over circumcision and
so they came to a general conference
in Jerusalem
and James presided not Peter
James was the head of that early church
not Peter as some people will tell you
Peter had the keys to the kingdom that
was James
and as he presided over that meeting
the Bible tells us there in Acts 15 32
that there were prophets there
that when they had made the decision of
the council the prophets confirmed that
this was God's will for the church
and confirmed them in the decision they
made confirmed them in the doctrinal
stand that they took
and preserved unity in the church